dans l'actualité ce soir la chine en
flammes le parlement européen nicolas
sarkozy venu exposer son programme a été
vivement pris à partie sur sa présence à
la cérémonie olympiques on ne peuvent
pas voler côté un quart de l'humanité a
répondu le président de la république
nouveau drame de l'immigration
clandestine au large de l'espagne cette
fois des familles entières avaient
embarqué en provenance d'afrique et en
compte neuf enfants de 1 à 4 ans parmi
les 14 victimes à londres le meurtrier
présumé des deux étudiants français
n'aurait pas agi seuls deux autres
personnes sont interrogées une troisième
considéré comme très dangereuse vient
d'être arrêté la rechute des bourses
mondiales paris revient à son plus bas
niveau depuis trois ans faut-il
s'attendre à une crise économique plus
profonde que prévu
éléments de réponse dans un instant à
l'heure des vacances cette mise en garde
aux propriétaires de piscines la plupart
des alarmes ne serait pas fiable le
gouvernement retire du marché cinq des
six modèles en vente
enfin le tour de france victoire du
jeune espoir italien rico surnommé le
cobra dans le massif central
schumacher victime d'une chute perd son
maillot jaune au profit du
luxembourgeois
kirschen bonsoir et bienvenue à tous
d'abord donc cette séance survoltée au
parlement européen nicolas sarkozy en
tant que président de l'union était venu
exposer ses priorités mais c'est la
question de la chine et des jeux
olympiques qui a enflammé les débats
le choix du président de la république
de se rendre sur place a été vivement
contestée à strasbourg françois
beaudonnet frédéric sur le monde
a strasbourg lé tout nouveau président
de l'europe était venu comme le veut la
coutume les priorités de la france l'est
devant les députés européens
nicolas sarkozy est très vite rattrapé
par l'annoncé de son voyage à pékin pour
les jeux olympiques
vous allez manger avec des baguettes
avec le président de chine pour ouvrir
les jeux olympiques
bon appétit moi je penserai à tous les
prisonniers qui croupissent dans
l'épisode prisons chinoises
moi je penserai à tous ceux qui sont
arrêtés moi je penserai à tous ceux qui
sont maltraités au tibet quand vous
écrirez vos mémoires vous rebours eux
vous regretterez ce que vous avez fait
monsieur le président c'est une honte
c'est minable d'aller à l'ouverture des
jeux olympiques merci à ce moment précis
dans l'hémicycle
l'émotion est palpable nicolas sarkozy
dispose alors de quelques minutes pour
encaisser les coups et justifier sa
position je ne pense pas que ça soit un
choix intelligent et responsable
quand on a la responsabilité d'être le
président du conseil que de dire un
quart de l'humanité
on ne viendra pas on vous inflige une
humiliation aux yeux du monde entier
je veux y aller et je veux parler je
vais même aller plus loin de jeu prison
cohn bendit
il ya des choses que je ne dirais pas la
chine parce que la chine doit être
respectée mais il ya des choses que la
chine ne doit pas dire aux pays
européens et notamment à la france parce
que la france et les pays européens
doivent être respectés aux mêmes égards
que la chine
ce n'est pas à la chine de fixer mon
agenda et mes rendez vous s'en suit
alors deux heures de discussion animée
avec les députés climat immigration
agriculture toutes les priorités de la
france sont passés au crible
mais à la conférence de presse qui suit
sous le feu des questions le président
français durci le ton vis-à-vis de pékin
il rencontrera le dalaï lama s'il le
souhaite la question de savoir chez ace
qui serait interdit de de discuter avec
un prix nobel de la paix je me demande
bien qui pourrait interdire une chose
pareille voilà même si la majorité des
députés européens ne partage pas
l'opinion de daniel cohn bendit
celui ci a réussi son pari
placé pour les semaines à venir la chine
au coeur des discussions européennes
alors nicolas sarkozy prise à partie en
europe qu'en est-il en chine sa décision
d'aller à pékin lui vaut-elle la
reconnaissance des autorités ou de la
presse bonsoir pascal golomer vous êtes
notre correspondant là-bas quels sont
les commentaires on voi annonce de sa
venue à pékin n'a vraiment pas
déclencher un fol enthousiasme dans les
médias chinois comme si le mal était
fait en quelque sorte certains journaux
parlent même de victoire de la
diplomatie chinoise qui aurait fait
plier la france on ne lâchant rien
finalement sur le dossier tibétain mise
à part deux réunions qui n'ont abouti à
rien avec les émissaires du dalaï lama
le gouvernement lui elle se veut
magnanime le porte parole du ministère
des affaires étrangères nous disait cet
après midi qu'il était temps d'ouvrir un
nouveau chapitre dans les relations
entre les deux pays tout en insistant
sur le fait que c'était nicolas sarkozy
le responsable de la détérioration de
ses relations un président français dont
on apprécie guère ici les hésitations
les volte face et puis les postures
qu'il a pu prendre au cours de ces
dernières semaines
il n'a pas la cote non plus auprès des
internautes d'après une consultation
organisée cette semaine et à laquelle
ont participé près de deux cent mille
personnes et biens 80% des sondés ne
veulent pas le voir venir aux jeux
olympiques les propos qu'il a tenu
aujourd'hui à strasbourg qui ne sont pas
encore commenté officiellement entre
autres pour cause de décalage horaire et
à bien ces propos ne vont certainement
pas améliorer sa popularité
merci pascal un nouveau drame je vous le
disais de l'immigration clandestine
encore un des hommes et des femmes qui
pensaient embarquer vers la terre
promise et qui ont rencontré la mort
entre l'afrique et l'espagne la
nouveauté cette fois c'est qu'il ya de
nombreux enfants parmi les 14 victimes
claude santerre ils sont arrivés
complètement épuisé après cinq jours en
mer parmi ces candidats à l'immigration
beaucoup de femmes et des enfants
ces images ont été tournées la nuit
dernière à almeria un port situé au sud
de l'espagne
la barque des réfugiés a été repéré à 65
kilomètres du rivage
d'abord les garde-côtes trouve 33
clandestins à bout de force durant la
traversée
quinze personnes ont trouvé la mort
leurs corps auraient été jetés par
dessus bord parmi les quinze décès des
neuf enfants le plus grand avec quatre
chats moquerait survivants sont tous
dans un état de faiblesse extrême made
in canada mais à la marque pour les
femmes qui ont perdu leurs enfants
on essaie en plus de leur apporter une
aide psychologique schéma longtemps la
vache est offert d'après les premières
informations ces rescapés viennent
d'afrique du nord
il cherchait à gagner le sud de
l'espagne en visite en grèce le premier
ministre espagnol a vivement réagi il
parle d'une tragédie insupportable et il
exhorte les pays riches à aider
l'afrique chalet sumann hanche ces
derniers jours plusieurs centaines de
réfugiés sont arrivés à chaque fois les
garde-côtes ont découvrir des familles
entières avec une présence très
importante de femmes et d'enfants
l'année dernière selon une organisation
humanitaire espagnole 921 personnes ont
trouvé la mort lors de ces traversées
on en vient à l'économie avec le
plongeon des bourses mondiales nouveau
record à la baisse notamment à paris qui
atteint son plus bas niveau depuis trois
ans beaucoup pensaient que le pire était
passé
apparemment ça n'est pas le cas la crise
est plus grave que prévu et un climat de
profond pessimisme est en train de
s'installer en france comme partout
ailleurs
valérie le rouge david fossard des
ventes de logements neufs en baisse de
28% un moral des ménages à son plus bas
niveau depuis vingt ans des faillites
d'entreprises qui bondissent et la
production industrielle en recul de 2,3
pour cent en mai dernier
tous les indicateurs virent au rouge et
de nombreuses pme ressentent ce
ralentissement de l'économie dans cet
atelier de pièces métalliques pour
l'industrie l'activité a baissé de 10 %
l'an passé et le carnet de commandes
reste bien maigre
c'est comme en deviennent goutte à
goutte et donc les personnes viennent
chercher leur fils au fur à mesure et
c'est vrai que là en ce moment il n'y a
pas beaucoup de fiches à quoi ça
ressemble à une quinzaine de fiches par
par secteur de machines là on va dire de
3 cette entreprise fournit notamment
l'industrie automobile
mais quel que soit le secteur un même
constat avec le client au téléphone
paraît que les gens ont peur ont peur de
passer les commandes ont peur de
s'engager je pense ce que la pme subi
les grands groupes lviv aussi ces
derniers jours ups veolia marks &
spencer ou carrefour ont annoncé des
résultats en baisse l'action du grand
distributeur a d'ailleurs dévissé de 8 %
aujourd'hui
car les analystes savent que le trou
d'air risque de durer les conséquences
de la crise d'actrice de matières
premières du pétrole et la crise
financière sont encore à venir pour nos
économies en constatant un mauvais
deuxième semestre et un mauvais début
d'année 2009
et c'est ça qui tentera effectivement
d'impact et disons les marchés boursiers
preuve que la bourse paris sur un avenir
sombre de ces grandes entreprises le cac
40 a perdu 25% de sa valeur depuis le
début de l'année une mauvaise nouvelle
pour les patrons les actionnaires mais
aussi pour les salariés des entreprises
sont contraintes de réduire la voilure
et donc notamment de réduire les
embauches ça a déjà commencé alors ça ne
voit pas trop parce qu'on a encore le
papy boom se dire beaucoup de départs à
la retraite mais au-delà de cela on se
rend compte les entreprises aujourd'hui
malheureusement commencent à licencier
ici ou là dans beaucoup de secteurs
d'activité ce qui veut dire que dès la
rentrée prochaine on peut avoir une
augmentation du chômage et les plus
pessimistes ne prévoit pas
d'amélioration avant le début 2010 car
la crise visible en france comme dans
l'ensemble des pays industrialisés à
londres l'enquète sur le meurtre des
deux étudiants français n'est pas
terminé on a appris aujourd'hui que deux
autres suspects un homme et une femme
sont entendus par la police
une troisième personne considérée comme
dangereuse c'est l'expression de
scotland yard vient à son tour d'être
arrêté sur place maryse burgot laurent
des bois devant ce tribunal de greenwich
dans le sud de londres le meurtrier
présumé comparaît nigel farmer est un
marginal rice df
sans emploi il a l'air hagard le regard
absent
ses mains sont très abîmées par des
brûlures soudain son visage sans
expression s'anime ses lèvres tremblent
à l'énoncé de sa mise en examen pour
double meurtre
accusés d'avoir commis de crime
frénétique et très brutaux il quitte le
palais de justice dans ce fourgon à
nantes avec lui ses mystères
car s'il est le meurtrier présumé des
deux étudiants il peut ne pas avoir agi
seul la police cherche d'éventuels
complices
scotland yard vient d'ailleurs d'arrêter
un homme âgé de 23 ans il s'appelle
daniel sonnex il est dangereux il serait
impliqué lui aussi dans les meurtres
pendant ce temps dans un commissariat du
sud de londres deux autres suspects un
homme de 35 ans et une femme de 25 ans
sont toujours en cours d'interrogatoire
le calvaire de laurent bonomo et de
gabriel fait rêve semble leur avoir été
infligée par plusieurs personnes
en bref un accident d'avion en haute
savoie un avion de tourisme il s'est
écrasé en début d'après midi près de
morzine
il y avait à bord deux adultes et deux
enfants aucun n'a survécu
l'appareil avait été loué un peu plus
tôt club aéronautique d'annemasse la
polémique ne faiblit pas après les
accusations de ségolène royal suite à la
mise à sac de son appartement
l'ex candidate en a dit un peu plus
aujourd'hui elle pense qu'elle a été
suivie ou mises sur écoute
elle fait état également de coincidence
troublantes selon elle alors que sait-on
exactement d effraction qui ont eu lieu
à son domicile où on l enquête
réponse avec audrey goutard emmanuel
maurel ségolène royal persiste et signe
cet après midi en visite à niort elle a
de nouveau dénoncé ce qu'elle appelle
une tentative d'intimidation politiques
je continuerai à parler malgré les
intimidations
malgré les insultes malgré les injures
j'entends des choses hallucinantes qui
sait qu'ils sont dit y compris sur mon
état mental
ce matin déjà à la responsable
socialiste avait réaffirmé faire l'objet
de surveillances fait soit je suis
écouté soit je suis suivie depuis mon
lieu de travail jusqu'à mon domicile
c'est une évidence mais face à ces
affirmations la ministre de l'intérieur
oppose un tout autre son de cloche
ce sont des propos qui ne correspondent
à rien je pense que quand on est un
responsable politique et il faut faire
attention à ce que l'on dit en effet les
choses ne sont peut-être pas aussi
évidente que la fiancée goolen royal en
tout la leader socialiste a été victime
de trois cambriolages en deux ans pour
l'un d'eux au moins commis en 2006 la
motivation crapuleuse ne fait aucun
doute
l'empreinte d'une cambrioleuses bien
connu de la police avait été découverte
une jeune femme toujours en fuite
lors de la dernière intrusion il n'y a
pas eu de vol mais des papiers
personnels ont été déplacées et froissé
parmi eux la plainte du précédent
cambriolage que la propriétaire des
lieux avait rangé sous la télévision
la preuve pour madame royal d'une mise
en scène les policiers eux penchent
plutôt pour des voleurs à la recherche
d'argent liquide
enfin ségolène royal craignant d'être
écouté les enquêteurs se sont assuré qu
aucun micro n'avait été branché dans son
appartement et que son téléphone n'était
pas piégé alors tentative d'intimidation
fomenté par des ennemis politiques ou
cambriolage crapuleux dans un
appartement peu sécurisé pour le moment
les deux pistes restent ouvertes et
précision ce soir d'une proche de
ségolène royal la députée aurélie
filippetti ségolène royal ne peut pas
apporter la preuve d'une implication du
pouvoir ce n'est pas à elle de le faire
il ya un faisceau d'indicés fin de
citation en bref des nouvelles de l'
alerte nucléaire au tricastin malgré une
réduction des concentrations d'uranium
dans les autres surfaces les autorités
ont décidé de maintenir les précautions
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire devait
effectuer le nouveau prélèvement ce soir
image signée christophe la rocca si vous
possédez une piscine ou qu'il y en a une
sur le lieu de vos vacances ce qui suit
vous concerne le gouvernement saisie par
la commission de sécurité des
consommateurs estime que la plupart des
alarmes ne sont pas fiables
cinq des six modèles en vente vont être
retirés du marché florence mavic pascal
caron
depuis 2003 une loi impose
l'installation d'un dispositif de
sécurité autour des piscines
particulière on en dénombre 1 million en
france
la plupart des familles ont choisi une
alarme dite d'immersion l'appareil est
censé détecter la chute dans l'eau d'un
jeune enfant ne sachant pas encore nagé
en juin la commission de sécurité des
consommateurs a mis en cause la
fiabilité de ce type d'alarmé après des
tests complémentaires les pouvoirs
publics demandent le retrait du marché
des cinq modèles suivants parmi les plus
vendus aqualarm senser premium sécurisé
pour al poule
bullguard un courrier sera adressé aux
propriétaires détenteurs de ce type
d'armes pour les inciter à la remplacer
mais qui paiera la facture
le gouvernement ne s'engage pas il ya
d'autres modes de protection comme les
barrières les volets roulants ou les
abris je vais vous dire il ya un dernier
point c'est que la meilleure des
vigilances la meilleure des sécurités
c'est la vigilance des parents
la commission de sécurité des
consommateurs souhaitent une mesure plus
radicale encore le retrait du marché de
toute la gamme des alarmes d'immersion
la politique qui sont les ministres les
plus courageux talentueux volontariste
un classement a été établi par des
journalistes français et étrangers aussi
et des politologues réunis par le
magazine le point en partenariat avec
france 2 un peu plus d'un an après la
formation du gouvernement
voici ce palmarès en quelque sorte avec
alix bouilhaguet sébastien laffargue
avait été gentille
or il a planché ce jury de journalistes
et politologues pour noter les ministres
en tête de leur palmarès tableau
d'honneur pour xavier bertrand 14 sur 20
pour le ministre des affaires sociales
au coude à coude
xavier darcos et martin hirsch le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
effectue même une belle progression par
rapport au classement de l'année
dernière souvent à chaque le cartable un
tacle de fournitures pour lui la fermeté
à payer dans cette année nous avons
montré comme le souhaitait le présent
république que ce qu'on avait promis on
le ferait voilà on a tenu
6e place et mentions assez bien pour le
premier ministre françois fillon qui
frôlent les 13 sur 20 françois fillon
est très bien noté sur la volonté de
réformer le pays
mais assez mal notés sur sa capacité
médiatique a expliqué médiatiquement
c'est cesser ces réformes ont le job
sans aux faibles en revanche cours de
rattrapage impératif cet été pour fadela
amara jean louis borloo et rachida dati
leurs notes décroche tout juste la
moyenne
enfin les recalés aux sports bernard
laporte à l'aménagement du territoire
hubert falco à la coopération alain
joyandet
5 sur 20 de moyenne attention à
l'expulsion l'actualité à l'étranger
l'iran annonce de nouveaux tirs de
missiles c'est la troisième fois en
trois jours on l'évoqué tiers tous les
coups semblent permis dans cette guerre
des nerfs plusieurs experts sollicités
par la fp ont ainsi dévoilé qu'une photo
de ses tirs diffusé par téhéran a été
retouchée pour impressionner davantage
l'un des missiles à semble-t-il été
ajouté peut-être pour dissimuler un
échec en tout cas le ton continue à
monter israël affirme que son armée
n'aura pas peur de passer à l'action
les derniers préparatifs du grand rendez
vous diplomatiques prévues en france
dimanche le sommet de l'union pour la
méditerranée il va marquer le retour de
la syrie sur la scène internationale
c'est un pari de nicolas sarkozy mais il
est très discutée fallait-il invité le
président bachar el assad
voici les arguments des uns et des
autres scieries le débat avait
chrono bernard et christophe vignal
bachar al assad dans son costume de chef
d'état a clamé et respectable la syrie
est accusée pourtant de soutenir le
terrorisme pour déstabiliser son voisin
le liban damas aurait commandité le
meurtre de l'ancien premier ministre
rafic hariri ni de la marque comme celui
de l'ambassadeur de france à beyrouth
louis delamare tué de dix balles à bout
portant alors est ce bien utile de
recevoir à paris ce président qui sont
le souffle l'écrivain marek halter est
pur il revient de damas mais pour
antoine basbous spécialiste du monde
arabe
cette invitation ne présente aucune
garantie
c'est une invitation prématurée il
faudrait que assad comme kadhafi se
repentent et qu'il s'engage selon une
feuille de route pour plus de démocratie
pour son peuple et pour renoncer au
terrorisme d'état
moi je pars du principe que c'est avec
l'ennemi compare avec les amis nous
n'avons pas de problème l'infréquentable
syrie qui soutient les ennemis d'israël
comme le hezbollah libanais ou l'iran et
son président mahmoud ahmadinejad
l'homme qui veut rayer l'état hébreu de
la carte avec la participation de bachar
al-assad à la conférence sur l'union
pour la méditerranée aux côtés d'israël
un changement était possible le fait
qu'il se trouve dans la même pièce
peut-être pas la même table peut-être la
même temps pierre houde olmert le
premier ministre israélien
cette image qui est où tout le monde
arabe tous les membres musulmans aura vu
même pour cette image ça valait la peine
d l'invité assad voudrait jouer sur tous
les tableaux
l'iran pour se protéger c'est l'allié
stratégique c'est l'allié de croiser
sans cheat et la france c'est le pont
vers l'europe vers les fonds européens
ce week-end bachar al assad visitera la
france pour la troisième fois en 2001 sa
réception à l'hôtel de ville de paris
avait été émaillée d'incidents
toujours à l'étranger nous partons
maintenant aux pays bas c'est ce pays
qui détient le record d'europe de
l'expatriation la densité de population
y est très forte
les prix élevés résultat beaucoup vous
l'avez peut être constaté choisissent de
partir notamment en france dans les
campagnes ou ailleurs la vague
néerlandaise c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signé zine dine boudaoud
siden berkous bourbon l'archambault son
château fort ces belles demeures et ses
2000 habitants une jolie et paisible
contre et en auvergne depuis le 1er juin
le chef du village c'est lui harry
keiper venu tout droit de la haye aux
pays bas
la cuisine est goûteuse les produits
régionaux autant que possible en salsa
cha son épouse est aux petits soins avec
les clients elles maîtrisent déjà très
bien la langue de molière avant le
couple tenait un café dans son pays
aujourd'hui les propriétaires de ce
restaurant il voulait changer de vie
la région est très très belle ici avec
la nature l'espace et tout ça ça manque
un peu au pays bas l'espace et les gens
sont super gentils tous là conversant
sont arrivés pour avoir un déjeuner au
dîner donc oui une meilleure qualité de
vie voilà ce qui fait bouger les
néerlandais les prix de l'immobilier
rang de l'accession à la propriété
difficile et ce petit pays de 16
millions de personnes et où apparaissent
dans pour la moitié du prix de leur
maison ils peuvent en acquérir une à
l'étranger avec deux fois plus d espace
voilà la raison principale de leur
départ bien sûr ils disent que c'est
plus beau là bas mais si les prix ici
était plus bas qu'en france par exemple
il ne partirait pas évidemment banlieue
d'amsterdam
eva et martine van dorst 100 sur le
départ ces jeunes cadres
dans la police lui dans la communication
bouclent leurs valises
ils ont choisi la france sans doute le
vernis ou même le vin français et le
pays bien sûr les jeunes époux se sent
marie arnaud verne il ya cinq ans
aujourd'hui leur projet et d'y ouvrir un
gîte rural
la france veut nous offrir la chance de
réaliser nos deux projets chambres
d'hôtes l'été pour les touristes et
aussi le commerce de meubles anciens et
sam ces sommes la france peut nous
permettre de le faire tous les deux ans
et pour se faire une idée les époux van
dorst ont visité plusieurs villages de
l'allier voilà la bâtisse qu'il sent
jeta acheter son prix 280 mille euros
mais il hésite le village est très calme
un peu trop peut-être même si clairement
ferrand n'est pas très éloigné
en dépit de la douceur de vivre
apparente les hollandais sont nombreux à
imaginer une autre vie ailleurs chaque
année environ 30000 hollande et quittent
leur pays mais plus de la moitié va
s'installer tout à côté en belgique et
en allemagne avant tout pour échapper à
l'impôt mais aussi pour profiter des
prix de l'immobilier
un petit peu plus abordable
l'environnement avec une nouvelle
illustration des conséquences des
changements climatiques conséquences
très concrètes
edf doit modifier certaines de ses
installations
c'est le cas des centrales hydro
électriques installées sous les glaciers
leur existence est peu connu exemple la
mer de glace à chamonix qui recule
chaque année de façon très visible sur
place nicolas chateauneuf mathias second
ce sont les gardiens éternel des plus
hauts sommets alpins des glaciers
immense qui ont façonné ces paysages
majestueux
vu d'en haut tout semble immuable et
pourtant en dessous c'est la débâcle
c'est bien ce qui inquiète les
ingénieurs d'edf aujourd'hui ils
descendent sous la mer de glace pour
constater les dégâts
il y a deux ans cet immense grotte de
glace n'existait pas aujourd'hui c'est
pas revoir font chaque jour un peu plus
vite
il leur faut maintenant
il arrive parce que si edf surveille de
près la mer de glace c'est parce qu'on y
produit de l'électricité grâce à un
incroyable réseau de galeries creusées
au coeur de la montagne les eaux de
fonte du glacier sont récupérées puis
acheminés vers des turbines situées en
contrebas
de quoi alimenter une vive et 50000
personnes sans gaz à effet de serre mais
il y a un problème pour continuer à
produire de l'électricité edf doit
creuser de nouvelles galeries est la
dynamite est remonté le captage beaucoup
plus haut ce n'est qu'un début car
partout dans les alpes les glaciers font
de plus en plus vite sur cette gravure
du 19e le glacier d'argentière
descendant la vallée aujourd'hui il n'en
finit plus de reculer
même constat pour le glacier du tout
rouge celui des bouchons et des
spécialistes observent une accélération
du phénomène
la diminution des glaciers est
clairement liée au réchauffement du
climat
oui et on a un réchauffement qui est
marqué dans les alpes réchauffement
estivale depuis 25 ans à tel point que
la mer de glace pourrait reculer de 600
à 900 mètres dans les 30 prochaines
années
de plus en plus rapide de ces glaces 13
ans seuls n'est pas un phénomène isolé
la plupart des remplacé dans le monde
sont touchées de la même manière et cela
n'est pas prêt de s'arrêter
les répétitions du 14 juillet avec une
première ce matin à paris cette
parachutistes ont sauté d'un hélicoptère
à 1000 mètres au dessus du sol sautez
sur la capitale bien sûr si la météo le
permet ils renouvelleront ce seul jour j
et devront se poser au pied de la
tribune présidentielle et de l'obélisque
inconscient aux accidents ce 14 juillet
en assistera également au défilé de la
première promotion des réservistes des
pompiers de paris
signe particulier c'est volontaire de 17
à 18 ans sont pour la plupart recrutés
en banlieue parisienne
orolia guillemin marie cros les
chaussettes pas du tout réglementaire et
pantalon je suis bien
séance d'essayage pour les douze tout
nouveau réserviste des pompiers de paris
ça n'a l'air de rien et pour certains
enfilé la tenue c'est un peu le plus
beau jour de leur vie
ma le casque malak la goule l'éventail
ont les ranger ses ceintures en fin de
partie c'est que du bonheur et des
efforts alors dj le rêveur trois samedis
par mois en entraînement et deux ans de
formation intensive pour ses nouvelles
recrues tout de la région parisienne
en fait ça nous permet dans des zones où
on n'est pas forcément le mieux
accueilli vient de créer du lien avec
les habitants de ce quartier retour à la
maison en seine saint denis pour mathieu
et juin ceux qui habitent le 9-3 comme
on dit ne sont pas peu fiers de
représenter ici les pompiers paris
montre que l'on change de l'image des
gens quand on dit combien des banlieues
pour les gens que tu viens de la
banlieue tout ça quand on dit qu'on est
pompier base des fois ça peut quelqu'un
de sérieux et ils ont passé leur bac
dans le 93 c'est pas forcément
valorisant quand on le présente sur acv
ils ont réussi dans le 93 et je pense
que oui sont beaucoup plus méritant que
certains sur le terrain dès le mois
prochain pour porter secours aux
victimes
mais d'ici là mathieu et les autres se
retrouveront le 14 juillet sur les
champs elysées le tour de france avec un
maillot jaune qui changent encore des
pôles schumacher victime d'une chute et
détrôner ce soir par le luxembourgeois
kirschen et c'est un jeune espoir
italien
ricco qui remporte l'étape sur place
nathanaël de rincquesen régis mater
depuis le début du tour c'est presque
devenu une tradition chaque jour dès les
premiers kilomètres de l'étape des
coureurs français fausse compagnie au
peloton
cima chavanel benoît vaugrenard et
freddy bichot multiplie les efforts
pendant 180 km sur les routes du massif
central
les trois hommes doivent se battre
contre la route qui s'élève le soleil
qui tape le peloton qui revient et la
pluie qui glace ça fait beaucoup pour
des échappées
la chaleur mais on a pris un coup depuis
aujourd'hui ce qui a permis de refroidir
un petit peu mais ça reste toujours des
journées difficiles parce qu'il n'y a
pas trop de votre plat c'est toujours en
prise et tout le monde c'est toujours
difficile dans le peloton la tension est
palpable
cadel evans s'énerve contre un gendarme
qui a failli faire tomber
chavanel lui arrête les frais à 15
kilomètres de l'arrivée il a récupéré le
maillot de meilleur grimpeur
l'échappée est terminée débute alors une
nouvelle course riche en intensité en
rebondissements à 300 mètres de la ligne
stefan schumacher le maillot jaune
heurte la route d'un concurrent
il perd l'équilibré 32 secondes et sa
précieuse tunique pour cette première
arrivée au sommet valverde et evans sont
roue dans roue aps
mais c'est ricardo ricco l'italien qui
s'imposent les transalpins voient en lui
le futur pantani et en italie c'est un
compliment sur le podium
kim kirchen a sorti son plus beau
sourire depuis charlie gaulle il ya 50
ans aucun luxembourgeois n'avait porté
le maillot jaune
une rencontre maintenant elle est l'une
des athlètes françaises les plus réputés
elle représente une réelle chance de
médaille en escrime laura flessel
prépare ses jeux olympiques et nous a
ouvert ses portes à l'occasion des
récents championnats d'europe
portrait d'une combattante qui est aussi
une mère de famille accomplie
laurent boussier xavier luizet
un cri de rage un cri de passion pour
une volonté de vaincre qui malgré les
victoires et les médailles ne faiblit
pas ces sports de combat et si on vient
la force vive
on souhaite pas la peine de partir donc
c'est un sport de combat de laura
flessel escrimeuse on connaît déjà
presque tout championne du monde
championne d'europe cinq médailles
olympiques gagné à atlanta sydney
athènes un sourire et un regard élire on
connaît son bonheur de jeunes mamans son
amour pour sa famille mais aujourd'hui
l'objectif c'est fait qu'à un défi
qu'elle aborde à 36 ans avec une
motivation à saïda de donner le maximum
pour retrouver en fait oui l'association
du voleur a la sensation de cette
complicité qui nous force à nous
concentrer pour ramener une équipe non
pas pour moi mais pour l'ensemble de la
fédération l'ensemble de ma famille
l'ensemble de tous les gens tous ont
conscience et qui me permet de de
progresser en fait dans
et concentrés motivés dimanche dernier
aux championnats d'europe à kiev en
ukraine
laura flessel enchaîner les combats une
répétition grandeur nature pour encore
se perfectionner
elle aime le défi quand je disais donc
fort elle pouvoir montrer aux gens
qu'ils allaient le chien toujours une
championne et elle a soif de victoires
quand je la regarde entraînements c'est
junior au moins alors azzedine une
tigresse sur l'api un mental de tigres
et
dans quelques jours celle qu'on surnomme
la guêpe va commencer avec les autres
escrimeurs de l'équipe de france
un stage de trois semaines avant de
boucler ses bagages pour pékin question
maintenant quel rapport y at il entre la
haute couture et la photographie l'une
ne peut exister sans l'autre
mais l'autre vous allez le voir se
nourrit à l'occasion de l'une
illustration rencontre de la photo
d'arles c'est le couturier christian
lacroix célèbre arlésien par ailleurs
qui fait office de commissaire c'est
donc lui qui a choisi les artistes et
les expositions sur place isabelle
weschler didier da l'homme qui froisse
son panama est un enfant du pays il
arpente les ruelles de sa ville natale
comme ils fouillent sa mémoire
commissaires invités des rencontres
internationales de la photo christian
lacroix a choisi de montrer le travail
des photographes dans et au delà du
monde de la mode
il a cherché aussi comment l'histoire et
la culture de sa ville ont influencé sa
création en exposant ses carnets de
collage le couturier dévoile comment
naissent ces modèles comment tout peut
l'inspirer et dans les préparatifs il ne
laisse pas grand chose au hasard
par contre c'est pas notre nom
c'est en train de sanctions jusqu'à
mettre les doigts dans la peinture
fraîche il s'était éloigné d'arles pour
visiter d'autres rivages
le voici revenu dans son centre de
gravité remontant le fil rouge de cette
vocation airs et la ville d'art je me
suis dit mais je pense que c'est à cause
de l'attitude de l'élégance du racisme
de ces femmes digitales et des toreros
qui m'ont donné le goût de la parure et
de la halle théâtralisation du quotidien
et partout des clins d'oeil décalé comme
ici delphine seyrig dans les archives de
l'émission dim dam dom la croix le
collectionneur de photos rejoint
l'utilisateur professionnel mais va
toujours voir un peu plus loin pour moi
la photo c'est un miroir la photo c'est
un moyen de remonter le fil du temps
c'est c'est la mémoire bien entendu mais
c'est aussi quelque chose qui m'a
toujours transporter vers un ailleurs
plus plus spirituelle autant que la
peinture récent lacroix cherche au delà
du miroir de l'apparence comme au delà
du vêtement une vérité plus profonde
une sorte de carte et diem pour défier
la mort à une soixantaine d'expositions
sont donc à découvrir jusqu'au 14
septembre avant de refermer ce journal
je vous en rappelle deux des principaux
titres la chine en flammes le parlement
européen nicolas sarkozy qui était venu
exposer son programme pour les six mois
à venir a été vivement pris à partie sur
sa présence à la cérémonie olympique qui
a dit que personne ne l'empêchera de
rencontrer le dalaï lama s'il le
souhaite
et puis à londres le meurtrier présumé
des deux étudiants français n'aurait pas
agi seuls deux autres personnes sont
actuellement interrogés et une troisième
considérée comme dangereuse par scotland
yard a été arrêté en toute fin d'après
midi
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko point route valérie
maurice 20h50 les carnets de vacances
d'envoyé spécial avec guilaine chenu et
françoise joly très bonnes vacances si
vous avez le plaisir d'en prendre
l'indicé françoise laborde que vous
retrouverez à 20 heures en attendant
demain ce sera élise lucet à 13h et
laurent delahousse ce week-end une
pensée amicale aussi pour celui qui
tire sa révérence ce soir même dans une
autre maison très bonne soirée
l'info en continu 7 sur france 2 point
fr
non